that is both satisfying and disgusting
I've seen them on people in shows and I
don't really think about black guys that
much but I do see them I do notice and
I'm like yeah maybe one day I'll get out
of there
I think blackheads like you can see them
very clearly like you can definitely see
it on my face I have never noticed
blackheads on your face oh that's nice
I like to think I have nice skin I've
got like blackheads I guess but they're
just enormous pore it sounds like an all
ripe pasta like I'll have the B or e I
have my doubts that they will work it's
a lot of instructions it just looks like
an advanced like band-aid it's a
band-aid from The Fifth Element
thoroughly wet your nose so I should
wipe my nose first right
just a little devil because the nose
need to be soaked or moist dry hands
peel strip off plastic liner I touched
the inside I wasn't supposed to was I
this is like the tattoo the fake tattoo
things are good all right screw it I'm
going for hay like this is gonna like
rip the skin off okay so now we wait
right carefully do this oh that is both
satisfying and disgusting guess it's
somewhat clean yeah you get clean nose
it feels like I'm waxing my body
[Music]
Oh God whoo
it looks crazy kind of gross a lot of
them oh my eyes are really starting to
water actually it's like
it definitely pulled it out plug it you
should have shale it's like it's like a
little forest that's really kind of
gross
oh yeah that's a that's intense that's a
rush that's that's intense pow I didn't
know all this stuff was up my nose I I
feel 10 pounds lighter yeah I feel I
feel cleaner
I feel more pure I didn't expect to pull
anything off like I I guess I was under
like the illusion that I don't have
blackheads I mean I don't know I'm like
I'm nervous that I've disturbed the
balance on my skin
taking it off I did kind of feel like a
snake shedding its skin I probably want
to do this once a week now I don't know
if this exists I would do it again if
someone bought me the strips
[Music]
Oh